Tenemos una función que es igual a 2 -
8x² + 32x⁴ - 128x⁶ con más y más términos,
definida como una serie infinita. Lo que quiero
explorar en este video es si hay alguna otra forma
de escribir esta función que no sea en forma
de serie infinita. En estos momentos, algunos
de ustedes pueden estar pensando: "Mmm, esto se
parece a una serie geométrica del lado derecho,
a una serie geométrica infinita". Y conocemos
la suma de la serie geométrica infinita, si
es que converge, podemos intentar expresarla así.
Empezamos comprobando que es una serie geométrica
infinita. Para que sea una serie geométrica
infinita, cada término sucesivo debe ser igual al
término anterior multiplicado por una razón común.
Para pasar de 2 a 8x² ¿por cuánto lo tenemos que
multiplicar? Lo tenemos que multiplicar por -4x².
Ahora, si multiplicamos (-8x²) (-4x²), ¿qué nos
queda? Menos 8 x -4 es más 32 y x² por x² es x⁴, sí
coincide. Y luego multiplicamos eso por -4x²,
y en efecto nos queda -128x⁶. Esta sí parece ser
una serie geométrica infinita del lado derecho,
incluso la podemos reescribir como: f(x) =
Σ desde que n = 0 hasta el ∞ de, ponemos el
primer término, y luego ponemos la razón común
-4x² elevado a la potencia n. Verifiquemos que
funciona cuando n = 0, esto es igual a 1 y 2 por
1 es 2. Efectivamente es nuestro primer término. A
eso le vamos a sumar el término de la serie cuando
n = 1, que es igual a 2 (-4x²), y resulta en este
término de aquí. Y parece como que sí funciona.
Ahora, ¿cuál es la suma de una serie geométrica
infinita como esta? La suma va a ser un número
finito, si el valor absoluto de la razón común
es menor que 1. Antes que nada, pensemos en bajo
qué circunstancias el valor absoluto de la razón
común es menor que 1, eso nos ayuda a encontrar
el radio de convergencia, y si x está en esa zona,
si está en ese intervalo, entonces podemos
encontrar una forma de definir a esta función
que no sea una serie geométrica infinita. Si nos
preguntamos ¿en qué situaciones converge?, ¿en qué
situaciones es igual a un valor finito? Eso sucede
cuando el valor absoluto de la razón común es ˂
1. Veamos si podemos simplificar un poco esta
expresión. No importa cuál sea el valor de x,
x² siempre va a ser positivo, por lo que toda
esta expresión siempre es negativa, y si sacamos
su valor absoluto es igual a 4x², que siempre es
positivo, esto siempre es igual a 4x², que tiene
que ser ˂ 1. También podemos decir que x² tiene
que ser ˂ ¼, es decir: x tiene que ser ˂ ½ y ˃ -½.
Si x está en cualquier punto de este intervalo,
y la elevamos al cuadrado, va a ser menor que ¼,
el punto ½, si lo elevamos al cuadrado, es igual
a ¼, y el punto -½, si lo elevamos al cuadrado,
es igual a ¼, pero para valores absolutos menores
va a ser ˃ ¼, esto es lo que nos está diciendo
este intervalo. Otra forma de decirlo es que
el | x | tiene que ser ˃ ½. Acabamos de definir
el intervalo sobre el cual la serie infinita
converge, también podemos decir que el radio de
convergencia de la serie -radio de convergencia,
de convergencia- es ½, y x puede subir o bajar ½
a partir del 0. Ya que encontramos las condiciones
de convergencia de la serie, reescribámosla. Esta
función es igual a -ya conocemos el valor de la
suma de series geométricas infinitas-, es igual
al primer término entre 1 menos la razón común,
-4x². Podemos reescribir nuestra función como:
2 / 1 menos un número negativo nos queda como un
+, + 4x², y esto es para los valores absolutos de
x menores a un medio. Este es el intervalo
de convergencia, y listo, ya terminamos.